[Music]
right now as you're listening to this
you are being robbed a chunk of
everything your hard work creates is
being stolen from you and it's a system
called capitalism that's robbing you
every day when you check in to work for
your boss you are being taken advantage
of and stolen from
you're being deprived of the full value
of what you contribute
let me break it down a capitalist isn't
someone in a top hat burning library
books
to run a misery factory anyone who puts
forward capital
money to set workers in motion becomes
thereby a capitalist that is to say
they're acting as a capitalist
and what's their goal people will tell
you it's innovation or competition
but down the real world it's pretty
simple
capitalists have one goal and that goal
is to turn a profit
pursuing profits to accumulate money is
just how capitalism works
that's the nature of the beast it's the
single impulse of capitalism
that doesn't make capitalists personally
greedy though some might be
we're not even talking about good or
evil here capitalists need to maximize
profit to the exclusion of all other
considerations or they'll get eaten up
by
capitalists who are smarter or more
ruthless than them
that's the jungle law of the market so
capitalists need profit to survive
but where does this profit come from and
that's where you come in
literally profit comes from you here's a
little thought experiment
meet harold harold has a chain of
buildings full of kitchens full of
ingredients
but harold doesn't know how to make a
burger himself how does harold get
someone to make enough burgers
that he can sell them and turn up profit
it's not a trick question
he pays you because you know how to make
really good burgers
the money he uses to pay you is what we
call capital
that's money used to set production into
motion
let's say harold spent thousand dollars
buying all the ingredients in the
restaurant and after you work for a few
weeks there
turning the ingredients into burgers
they brought in
three thousand dollars not bad you added
two thousand dollars worth of value
to the ingredients but wait you don't
get
all the money because harold now has
three thousand dollars on his hands
one thousand of that is just making up
for the cost of the ingredients
and if you were paid for the full value
of your labor you'd be making two
thousand
but then harold would only be breaking
even on the burgers
and he needs to make a profit in order
to survive
so harold does not pay you for the full
value of your labor
maybe he pays you just a thousand of the
value you produce
maybe he pays you 1500. no matter what
you've been stolen from you spent more
of your labor
than you were compensated for but here's
the dirty truth
the story doesn't end with you and
harold this process plays out across
your city or town
your state the country the entire world
the rich get richer
and the little guy barely gets by we
call the process
a boss's stealing from you exploitation
we don't mean that in an emotional sense
about how we feel about it
but something that's actually a
documented economic phenomenon
the gap between how much the worker
produces
and how much they get paid exploitation
is a universal feature
of capitalist economies and it never
ends
the system requires more and more
exploitation
paying workers less making them work
more or making them more productive
without increasing their wages
when you see in the newspaper that a
corporation's recording
record profits that is what they are
doing your hard work is producing more
value
but you're not getting enough
compensation in return
there are tens of thousands of heralds
out there but billions of people
just like you you and harold are two
different types of people
you belong to two different classes
there's a capitalist who owns
the means to produce goods and services
and there's the workers who only have
their own labor to survive on
the capitalists appropriate the value
that the workers labor creates
and keep it for themselves and you are
not immune from
it at any job you work at the condition
of your
employment is that you produce more by
your labor
then you get paid so in the capitalist
system
no one is paid what they're worth all
profit is value extraction and that
means that all profit is theft
from you
this is richard wolff professor of
economics at the new school
university for the gravel institute
[Music]
[Music]
you